Salut ! J'espère que vous allez bien, c'est dimanche matin
Je me suis dis : "On va faire un truc bien fun en ce dimanche matin"
On va parler de Maths !
C'est un suicide Youtubesque, J'en ai bien conscience
Avant de vous donner cette astuce cool
Je vous donne la solution de l’énigme d'hier
La première solution de l'énigme
c'était treize , vous aboutissez à treize
au final, donc c'était la première partie
de l'énigme globale
pour la deuxième, il y avait les deux rebus pour faire la charade
donc mon premier étais "L'oiseau y couve ses œufs"
Donc , un nid. Mon deuxième c'était une équation
Un quatre quart divisé par quatre
quatre en chiffre romain
donc un quart, et mon tout précédait mon premier et mon second
dans une célèbre phrase mnémotechnique
que j'ai beaucoup entendu dans ma jeunesse
"Mais où est donc Or ni car ?"
et donc qu'est-ce qui précédé ni et car ? C'est Or
Donc la deuxième partie de l'énigme globale et Or
Donc treize - or , trésor
c'était pas très compliqué mais il fallait prendre le temps de tout faire
et donc aujourd'hui
un astuce de mathématiques pour divisé un peu plus facilement de tête
Générique !
Tout au long de l'année je vous ai donner régulièrement des astuces
pour le calcul mental ou pour les maths
j'ai même fait une playlist pour ça qui s'appelle "trucs de maths"
y'a pas beaucoup de chose sur la division par ce qu'il
n'y a pas beaucoup d’astuce en fait sur la division
j'ai hésité à un moment donner à ré-apprendre
à faire une division à la main  pour faire une division sans calculatrice
puis je me suis demandé si peut être ça allait vous saouler
Si vraiment vous voulez une vidéo là dessus mettez le dans les commentaires
et je verrais suivant le nombre de personne qui le réclament si je le fais ou pas
mais je suis pas persuadé que ce soit pertinent
Mais aujourd'hui, il y a quelque choses dont je me sers spontanément
qui peut les intéresser
c'est pas tant pour mieux la résoudre que pour mieux la comprendre
première astuce : vous regarder le nombre que vous avez à diviser
Vous regarder la fin de ce nombre, son dernier chiffre
Celui des unités
si il se termine par 2 ; 4 ; 6 ou 8
ça veux dire qu'il est divisible par 2
c'est une informations que vous savez, il est pair
il est divisible par 2, si il se termine par 5 ça veux dire qu'il est divisible par 5 sans retenue
et si il se termine par 0 , ça veux dire qu'il est divisible par 10 sans retenue
deuxième astuce que j'utilise , vous pouvez faire rapidement la somme des chiffres qui composent le nombre
si c'est 197 vous faite 1 + 9 + 7 , ça fait 17 par exemple
Vous le réduisez au maximum par exemple pour 17
j'aurais fait 1+7 =8
jusqu'à tant qu'il vous reste qu'un seul chiffre
ça ce fait très rapidement de tête
et si ce résultat de réduction est un multiple de 3
ça veux dire que vous pouvez diviser par 3
par exemple 168 ça fait 1+6 = 7 , +8 = 15
15 ça fait 1+5=6
6 c'est un multiple de 3 donc c'est divisible par 3
Troisième point et là on vas passer très vite dessus
c'est exactement la même chose que le précédent
mais pour 9
si votre réduction final est un multiple de 9
ça veux dire que le nombre est divisible par 9
si on prend 225 ça fait 2+2=4 , +5=9
donc 225 c'est divisible par 9
et en fait ça fait 25x9
Quatrième petit Tips !
si c'est divisible par 2, comme on a vu dans le premier tips
et si en plus la somme réduite est un multiple de 3
comme on a vu dans le deuxième tips
alors vous savez que le nombre est  divisible simplement par 6
ça vous permet encore une fois de savoir où aller
et j'ai une dernière astuce pour voir rapidement si le nombre est divisible par 4
alors vous allez me dire 4 c'est 2 divisé par 2 c'est pas faux en soi
mais pour être sûr d'avoir intérêt à faire la double division
et que ça tombe juste, il suffit de regarder les deux dernier chiffres d'un grand nombre
c'est à dire le chiffre des unités et des dizaines
et si ces deux derniers chiffres sont divisibles par 4
ça veux dire que le grand nombre, peut importe ça taille, est divisible par 4
sans vérifier au préalable si je vous dis 849 616
Comme 16 est divisible par 4 je sais déjà que ce que je viens de vous dire est divisible par 4
Voici quelques astuces de division, celles que j'utilise personnellement
qui peuvent vous permettent d'avoir au moins un regard
si ce n'est pas de faire la division mentalement facilement
ça vous permet déjà de savoir comment situer qu'est-ce qui va permettre de diviser
j'espère que ça vous a plu si c'est la cas n'hésitez pas, mettez un pouce en l'air
Oui je sais c'est trash des maths le dimanche
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise ?
Demain on attaque une grosse semaine avec du mentalisme, du non-verbale
des explications, des invitées et encore plein de trucs cool
en tout cas que je trouve cool
Alors rendez vous demain à17h
Ciao !!